uh will give us an idea of the figures
then it's all pretty eye-watering
yes so just after seven o'clock this
morning shell announced they'd made 9.5
billion dollars in profit in the last
quarter of the year that equates to
around 8.2 billion pounds
um it's down on last uh quarter's record
figure of 11.5 billion but it's still
the second highest quarterly figure in
the company's history
um an indication really of the real boom
across the oil and gas industry since
the Russian invasion of Ukraine and I
think we can really get a sense of how
those figures have gone up over the past
year
um this latest uh quarterly figure more
than uh twice as much as the same period
um last year now why does this matter
well amid the cost of living crisis with
this huge hole in the National budget of
course this is fueling calls to expand
the windfall tax now opposition parties
uh have been calling for this for some
time now Ed miliband from labor already
this morning saying that this is proof
If any more were needed that the energy
companies need to be doing more to pay
their fair share while Millions across
the country struggle to pay their bills
now back last May the now prime minister
then Chancellor did announce a 25 uh
windfall tax on uh profits but much of
that could be offset as tax relief if
the companies invest in oil and tax oil
and gas projects
um now the opposition parties say they
should get rid of those tax breaks labor
say under their scheme they would raise
8 billion pounds to help pay for the
energy price cap Liz truss always argued
this was the wrong message to be sending
out earlier this morning when asked
about it and it seems aha we also said
we should be encouraging companies to
invest here to help with our energy
security however given that huge
budgetary black hole we know the
chancellor is facing the pressure will
be on him to look at this again I think
before the Autumn statement in November
I think you might be right Amanda thank
you